Narrator:
ST. LOUIS, MISSOURI,
FOR JON AND JOEY'S
INSANE FLAME GAME.
OH, UH, DO NOT TRY THIS AT HOME.
HOW DO YOU TAKE A CLASSIC GAME
LIKE JENGA TO THE NEXT LEVEL?
FIRST, YOU MAKE IT
EIGHT TIMES BIGGER.
AND THEN YOU SET IT ON FIRE.
HEY!
HOW ARE THEY NOT
BURNING THEIR HANDS?
Narrator:
GOOD QUESTION, HOT SHOT.
SCIENTISTS, OVER TO YOU.
THIS IS ALL THANKS
TO AN AMAZING GEL.
THIS GEL IS
A SPECIAL FIRE RETARDANT
MADE FROM A SUPER ABSORBENT
CROSS-LINKED POLYMER.
Linsell:
THIS IS AN INTERLINKING NETWORK
OF LONG-CHAIN MOLECULES
WITH SIDE CHAINS
THAT ARE STICKING OUT.
Kundu: WHEN THIS MATERIAL
IS EXPOSED TO WATER,
THE SMALL SIDE CHAINS
BECOME NEGATIVELY CHARGED.
THIS MEANS THAT
THEY REPEL EACH OTHER
AND UNFURL TO CREATE
A MUCH LARGER NETWORK.
THE NEGATIVE SIDE CHAINS
ALSO ATTRACT THE HYDROGEN
IN WATER MOLECULES,
WHICH IS SLIGHTLY POSITIVE.
THIS MEANS THAT LOADS OF WATER
IS TRAPPED INSIDE THE POLYMER
NETWORK STRUCTURE.
ONCE THE POLYMER HAS SOAKED UP
SEVERAL HUNDRED TIMES
ITS OWN WEIGHT IN WATER,
IT FORMS THE GEL THAT WE SEE
COVERING JON AND JOEY'S HANDS.
Kundu: WATER HAS A VERY HIGH
SPECIFIC HEAT CAPACITY,
WHICH MEANS IT TAKES
A LOT OF ENERGY
TO EVAPORATE IT
FROM A LIQUID INTO A GAS.
AND THIS MEANS IT'S
A REALLY GOOD CHOICE
FOR PROTECTING THEIR HANDS.
Narrator: JON, JOEY,
YOU'RE THE FIRST GUYS
TO NAIL FLAMING JENGA.
AND WE HOPE YOU'RE THE LAST.
I THINK IT SHOULD
GO WITHOUT SAYING,
BUT I'M GONNA SAY IT --
DON'T TRY THIS AT HOME.